great news from the White House today
just as president Trump supporters had
nearly abandoned all hope for a wall on
our southern border the White House
announces plans to divert 3.6 billion
dollars from military construction
projects to build the border wall we
will examine how likely it is that the
money makes it to the southern border
and what it means for 2020 then speaking
of 2020 a new poll spells bad news for
President Trump but it also spells bad
news for Joe Biden which is good news
for Elizabeth Warren which is good news
for President Trump how does that work
it's a complex poll we will break it
down over in the motherland the UK is
Prince Harry gives a hypocritical speech
on environmentalism the speech tells us
a lot more about the state of Western
religion than it does about science
finally some hope from left-wing
Hollywood all that and more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
we have a new sponsor today that I have
been waiting to tell you about I've been
so excited to tell you about it because
I simply love the product the product is
Daniels NYC beautiful exceptional luxury
leather briefcases at an incredibly
affordable price classic New York style
I'm a New Yorker pretty much my whole
life and it's just the best of New York
style it's got sort of fun little
patterns on the inside if you want to
get them a really nice high quality
leather it just looks great it feels
great it's really really high-quality
the reason I feel passionately about
this I have had briefcases for a long
time I've had really expensive
briefcases that I've gotten his hand me
downs I've had all sorts laptop bags and
none of them really worked I mean
they're just the old laptop bags are way
too big now and bulky they're like meant
for computers from the 90s not for new
laptops which are much smaller that was
hard back you know I have a beautiful
like Oscar ostrich briefcase that's
really hard it looks like it's out of
the 50s or 60s just doesn't work for the
way that we work today
Daniel's comes in with the perfect
design it's unbelievably slim it's
really sleek it's really smart looking
and yet you can fit a ton of stuff in
there it's got a special laptop case
even the buttons and things that fasten
are just really exceptionally high
quality I had been using I'm sorry to
say a backpack until I got my Daniels
briefcase because like all millenials I
just didn't want to pay five six hundred
bucks for a nice briefcase and I
couldn't find one that really looked
good and worked for me so I was carrying
around a backpack like I'm a 12 year old
school boy Daniels fixes that New York
city-based men's leather briefcase brand
and it's a brand you can afford before
you land the big job it actually may
help you land the big job by cutting out
the middlemen they sell directly to you
you can get a high quality luxury
leather briefcase for the incredibly
reasonable price of a hundred ninety
five bucks you're not going to find that
anywhere else you can compare that to
luxury brands that cost five hundred or
even more I just love this product I
simply love the thing this week my
listeners can get twenty five bucks off
their Daniels briefcase at Daniel's and
YC dot-com by using the promo code my
mi CH AE L at checkout 25 bucks off one
of their leather briefcases they're just
super plus you get free shipping again
get get it right right now it's so good
Daniel's NYC comm promo code Michael 25
bucks off a handcrafted high-quality
leather briefcase free shipping ditch
that old backpack start looking like a
grown-up
kiddos Daniel's NYC comm I love them and
you will too
great news beyond our briefcases and how
great we all will look with them great
news from the White House today it
actually came at yesterday in the
evening but the the news is finally
hitting this morning president Trump has
announced plans to divert 3.6 billion
dollars from military construction
projects to build the border wall this
is the most significant news on building
the border wall that we've had so far
there you know President Trump had been
telling people that he's built a lot of
wall there's a lot of new wall not just
replacing old wall then there was a
report that came out just a few months
ago from Customs and Border Protection
which showed that he hadn't built a
single inch of new wall he had replaced
old walls but in terms of new wall there
had been nothing a huge embarrassment a
huge vulnerability for the 2020 election
campaign then within the past few weeks
we got news from the Supreme Court the
president Trump's cash grab to take
about two and a half billion dollars
from military construction was allowed
to go through it was a 5-4 decision
shows you how important getting good
judges on the Supreme Court can be and
and this even Dwarfs that so what is
going to happen of this 3.6 billion half
of it will come from projects overseas
you know we have a ton of military
construction that we do all around the
world so half of it will come from that
half of the money will come from
domestic projects which means that
certain congressmen are going to be
extremely ticked off because they're
losing their earmarks and the White
House is going to need to massage that
and work with Congress which they've not
been extremely successful at so far but
perhaps that is already in the works I
should hope that it is because otherwise
Congress is going to raise a lot of
trouble about this either way the White
House is empowered
to do it still a very good start here
particularly after that SCOTUS ruling in
July that Trump could use two and a half
billion to to build the wall as well so
what did the two and a half billion get
us that first move that came in July two
and 1/2 billion permitted about 100
miles of a new border wall so that's in
addition to all the wall that's been
built over the past few decades now if
two and a half billion got 100 miles of
new wall then you just do the math this
three point six billion should get us
another 144 miles of wall so in the past
two months or so we've were looking at
an additional 244 miles of border wall
what does that mean obviously we're
looking at an almost two thousand mile
border with Mexico 244 miles doesn't
sound like a whole lot but you've got to
think of it in the perspective of the
wall that we already have I mean we have
been trying to build this wall since
1990 we've been trying to build this
wall since the first George Bush
administration and then that proceeded
beginning with George HW Bush through
Bill Clinton through George W Bush who
really ramped up efforts to build the
wall and actually got some bipartisan
buy-in even from Chuck Schumer who was
for the wall before he was against the
wall just like a lot of Democrats who
were for proposals before Republicans
were for them and now they're against
those proposals so all the way up
through that you got 649 miles of wall
like in the course of about 30 years you
got 649 miles of wall now you're also
not going to build 2,000 miles of wall
anyway right you're not going to build
wall over water you're not going to
build wall in certain places that are
not trafficked areas and are not
hotspots for traffickers and coyotes to
come through so 649 so far if you build
an additional 244 miles of wall then
you're looking at a 38% increase just
this year as you're going into the
election over the past 29 years that is
big news if you can say okay it took
nine years three presidents plus Obama
who didn't do anything who actually
halted a lot of that construction so for
presidents 29 years to get 649 then you
get a 38% increase over that in just one
term in with just one president that is
a pretty good pitch
you know we've said on this show for a
long time that the absence of the wall
of the new wall is a major campaign
vulnerability and I like to think the
president Trump heard that the I we know
that he likes to watch Fox and Friends I
hope that he likes to watch this show
and I hope that his aides listen to this
show as well either way other people
have been saying it too and it appears
that the White House has listened it's
very difficult for him to make his pitch
in 2022 his base to his supporters if a
major campaign promise like build the
wall which everybody was chanting
through the whole 2016 campaign if he
totally flops on that if President Trump
can now go to the public in 2020 and say
that he has expanded the wall by 38% or
he has laid the groundwork such that
we're right on track to expand the wall
by 38% in the face of hardcore
obstruction from the left and from many
people on the right that is real
progress it's not a big beautiful wall
that's ten feet higher that Mexico paid
for that goes from coast to coast sure
but people don't care about that I mean
his critics will use that as a way to
try to jab him and say he didn't give
you everything you want Trump supporters
don't really care about that I think
Trump supporters are very realistic and
realize that it this is a very difficult
task you're talking about a huge
architectural endeavor a massive
political endeavor with nearly
unprecedented obstruction if you get a
good chunk of it upwards a 40 percent
additional wall that's pretty good
that's a pretty good start good news
thankfully for the White House bad news
for the Democrats and actually there's
bad news for the Democrats that looks
like bad news for the White House that
is bad news for the White House
except it's also bad news for the
Democrats which means it's good news for
the White House how does that work
there's a new poll out
that shows that joe biden's lead in the
2020 Democratic presidential primary is
shrinking this is a poll from IBD TI PP
LMNOP w XY is it no it's a lot of
alphabet in there but this is a pretty
reliable poll IBD TI PP where was the
poll that most accurately predicted the
2016 general election and this poll has
Biden's lead diminishing and other
candidates rising and the poll has Biden
up 12 points on president Trump now this
is a complex poll and it has complex
implications so let's break it down if
Biden is diminishing in the poll he's
been the front-runner the whole time
since he announced even since before he
announced if he's diminishing Liz Warren
is surging so she's up in just the month
of August and she's up 7 points or
something according to this poll that
puts Liz Warren within four points of
Joe Biden but the poll still places
Biden as the best choice against
President Trump according to the poll
Biden is up 12 points on president Trump
Warren however when you look at her
head-to-head against President Trump is
only up three points on the president
which is not terribly significant I mean
that's basically a dead heat and it's
even more confusing it's even more
difficult because while the IBD ti PP
poll was the most accurate in the 2016
general election it wasn't actually
accurate it predicted that Trump would
win the popular vote by two percentage
points
he didn't win the popular vote at all he
actually lost the popular vote but he
won the electoral vote so you got to
take this poll even a good poll with a
grain of salt as you do of all polls so
what does this mean in terms of how we
should view the general election polls
how we should view the Democrat poll and
the question that's being debated in the
media right now in the left and right
media is is this poll good news for
Trump or bad news for Trump it actually
is both but there is a correct answer in
the end we'll get to that in one second
but first support for the michael
knowles show come
from our friends at rocket mortgage by
Quicken Loans I live in Los Angeles this
is a very difficult place to get a house
in why because you walking through the
neighborhoods and you say all that
little cottage looks pretty nice maybe I
owe it's ten million dollars okay all
right never mind keep looking very
difficult to find a good house
particularly when you're being paid
these shapiro wages and you're living in
a broom closet when i do find the right
house however at least getting the right
mortgage will be easy because rocket
mortgage makes it easy for most people
virtually everybody getting a mortgage
buying a home is the most difficult most
important most complex financial
decision they're ever going to make and
because I'm a millennial and I don't
know anything practical it's even more
difficult for me but fortunately their
mortgage experts number one goal is to
make the home buying process smoother
for you and for me
they have industry-leading online
lending technology rocket mortgages
there with award-winning client service
and support every step of the way when
you go into this when you go into a
decision that is so important for your
financial future and just for your life
generally why would you not go with the
best that doesn't make any sense go with
the best and rocket mortgages ranked
highest and customer satisfaction for
primary mortgage origination nine years
in a row
not even once or twice nine years in a
row they're ranked highest in mortgage
servicing five years in a row
go with the best when you work with them
you get more than just a loan because
rocket mortgage is more than just a
lender get started online today at
rocket mortgage.com slash anoles KO wles
Equal Housing lender licensed in all 50
states n MLS consumer access org number
30 30 rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans
push button get mortgage is this poll
good for Trump or bad for Trump first of
all I will put my cards on the table in
terms of how I view these polls
generally I am skeptical of the general
election polls specifically I am
skeptical of the polls that show Trump
losing in the general election is that
because I think Trump can't lose the
general absolutely not I think he's
vulnerable and he could lose the general
is it because I like Trump no I do like
Trump but that's not why
the reason that I'm distrustful of these
general election polls is first of all
the campaign has barely begun
forget the general campaign even the
Democratic primary campaign has barely
begun we're about to look at what the
third Democratic presidential debate
there's going to be 12 total we are not
even scratching the surface of where
this campaign is going to go so for the
Democratic candidates have pretty much
not attacked one another Kamala Harris
got a dig in at Joe Biden and Tulsi
Gabbard got a dig in and Kamala Harris
it's pretty much it otherwise they've
all been nice and they've all been going
after Trump they've said a lot of crazy
things but they've been nice to one
another the main reason that I don't
trust these general election polls it's
not even all that it's because a little
while ago there was a poll out that
showed that head-to-head Cory Booker
would be President Trump by a
significant margin and I don't know a
whole lot in this life folks I'm not
look I'm not Nostradamus I can't predict
the future but Cory Booker is not going
to beat Donald Trump for president he's
not gonna beat any of the Democrats to
get the nomination for president if he's
lucky he'll get to keep his Senate seat
Cory Booker ain't going to the White
House in 2020 folks and if a poll tells
you it is that tells you more about the
poll than it does about 2020 it is very
very early these polls are very very
wacky so I'm pretty much putting the
general election polls off to the side
for now doesn't mean they don't worry me
doesn't mean that they don't tell you
something but it's just so remote at
this point much more interesting than
the general election polls are the
primary polls the primaries polls right
now especially this IBD TI P people is
pretty much showing what we've been
saying the whole time the polls saying
Trump has vulnerabilities I've been
shouting that from the rooftop the poll
is saying a more moderate Democrat or at
least a Democrat who is perceived as
more moderate could possibly be
President Trump I've been saying that
all time and it shows that the Democrats
are radicalized
which is the key here Biden is tanking
Warren is surging Biden is the old guard
Biden has really held it virtually every
position throughout his entire career
and he doesn't have any actual beliefs
and he'll say whatever he wants to say
that if he thinks it's politically
convenient and he has no regard for the
truth so there's that part but at least
for most of his career he felt it was
convenient to be perceived as a moderate
Liz Warren is a dyed-in-the-wool
progressive she's been a progressive for
her entire public career and she spent
most of her career in academia at very
left-wing
universities which tends to make you
even more liberal even more radical and
more radical Democrats will have a much
more difficult time beating president
Trump this is reflected in all the polls
this is why Democrats are having a big
debate right now over electability and
you've got the Democrats who want to be
President Trump saying we need somebody
like a Joe Biden who might be a total
schmuck and doofus but at least he could
be President Trump in the general and
then you've got the progressive saying
who cares about electability what's
electability that doesn't mean anything
poll after poll after poll shows it and
you don't need the polls to show it you
just have your common sense if you if
the Democrats are gonna be running on
open borders abortion up until the
moment of birth and maybe even after the
moment of birth if you live in Virginia
under the Democratic governor Ralph
Northam or up until the moment of birth
in New York under the Democratic
governor and equal moe if they're gonna
be running on abolishing ice if they're
gonna be running on soak the rich spend
ninety three trillion dollars in the
green New Deal which virtually all of
the major Democratic presidential
candidates have endorsed if you're
running on that kind of stuff that's not
gonna play in Peoria that's not the way
to win a majority of Americans that's
not or a plurality of Americans and a
majority of voters that's not good news
bad news especially in this case in
particular for Joe Biden and you don't
need to just look at the poll and we
don't need to read the crystals and the
tea leaves like we're marianne
williamson
we don't need to just do that you can
see from the Biden campaign he is
terrified they are more nervous than any
presidential campaign I have seen
probably in my lifetime how do I know
that because they're already downplaying
expectations in the early primary and
caucus states they're already saying
don't expect us to win Iowa
so senior advisor to the Biden campaign
told a group of campaign reporters on
Tuesday in a background briefing so it's
on background the the advisor doesn't
want his name out there but he does want
to be quoted directly and this wasn't
just some guys speaking off-the-cuff
this was a senior decision from the
Biden campaign he said quote do I think
we have to win Iowa no where have we
heard that but we heard that from Rudy
Giuliani we heard that from a campaign
that I worked on from a very good man
named John Huntsman but a campaign that
did not end well and part of that was
because of poor decisions by the senior
campaign staff to give up Iowa campaigns
that are not doing well say well we're
gonna give up Iowa when campaigns that
are really not doing well say we're
gonna give up New Hampshire guess what
Joe Biden said not only did he say we're
giving up Iowa he said he might not win
New Hampshire this same senior advisor
who's talking to campaign reporters said
quote as you all know historically
there's an incredible home-field
advantage for a Massachusetts candidate
or a New Englander meaning Elizabeth
Warren who is surging who is eating Joe
Biden's lunch really tough news for them
you know this whole hey maybe we're not
going to win Iowa hey maybe we're not
gonna win New Hampshire first of all you
rarely get the two at the same time but
this is the sort of thing candidates say
two weeks out when they're when they
know that they're losing and they want
to tamp down expectations this is not
the sort of thing you say five months
out from the Iowa caucus especially when
you are the front-runner because Joe
Biden is only the front-runner on the
perception of his electability against
President Trump and the trouble
reflected in this poll reflected a lot
of other polls reflected in every crazy
soundbite you see on TV
on Twitter is that the Democrats are
radicalizing the problem is the minute
that the electability argument goes away
the minute he doesn't win Iowa doesn't
win New Hampshire he has nothing else
because the Democrats are not we're Joe
Biden is the Democrats are we're
Elizabeth Warren and Kamala Harris and
all the rest of those second-tier people
are bad news provide bad news for the
moderate Democratic contingent and this
is especially bad news as President
Trump seems poised and committed to
taking care of one of his biggest
weaknesses which is the wall and and
making matters worse for Democrats is at
least if you've got Biden in the picture
you've got a guy that we've all known
for 50 years who seems kind of
acceptable you know he's served at high
levels of government whatever people
could get past it we're not terrified
that he's going to totally destroy the
country well once you take him out of
the picture then you've got to look at
what these people are actually saying
because even Liz Warren or Kamala Harris
or bado Rourke or any of these people
they're relatively new faces in the
American political scene they haven't
been around since the 1720s when Joe
Biden first ran for dog catcher in the
colonies you know when you listen to
what they're saying you see that the
leading Republicans right now are saying
we need to build the wall we need to
support our Border Patrol we need to
defend our borders we need to
renegotiate trade deals we need to grow
jobs we need relative peace abroad what
are the leading Democrats saying not
just the fringe Democrats not just the
random people on Twitter the leading
Democrats well one of the leading
Democrats who the Democratic National
Chairman said is the future of the
Democratic Party
AOC and her friends are calling for
bailing domestic terrorists out of jail
so one party is saying let's build a
wall at support our laws let's keep us
safe the other party is clamoring to
bail domestic terrorists out of jail in
the form of the anti feh thugs who were
arrested 36 of them over the weekend
because they were attacking police
officers and they were attacking regular
old Paige
people who were waving American flags in
a kind of ironic troll ish straight
pride parade
that's aoc leader of the squad and
that's Ayane Presley the Ringo of the
squad Ayane Presley tweets at quote join
me right now in making a contribution a
contribution to a fund that would bail
these auntie fuh violent thugs out of
jail she goes on thank you to the Allies
and accomplices who stood in the gap and
laid their bodies on the line today in a
in a front hashtag LGBT hate March
doesn't seem like accurate syntax but
you know that's that's the squad for you
to everyone feeling unseen and
vulnerable today we got you equitable
outrage or destinies and freedoms are
tied just to remind you there were 20
patriotic Americans who were who were
engaged in this kind of troll ish
straight Pride Parade to make fun of the
left there were thousands of people
protesting them and getting violent with
them and attacking them the only people
who were unseen and vulnerable were the
200 people who were supporting President
Trump and waving American flags as well
as the police officers who were being
attacked by these thugs and tifo was not
unseen they were everywhere they vastly
outnumbered the Conservatives and the
aoc same thing called for money and
support for these organizations was
quote one way to support the local LGBTQ
community impacted by Boston's white
supremacist parade so now the straight
Pride Parade which was really just a
kind of patriotic parade is now being
rebranded by aoc as white supremacists
because she thinks that everybody who is
in her as a white supremacist including
Nancy Pelosi aoc goes on contribute to
the bail fund for the activists who put
themselves on the line protecting the
Boston community protecting them against
memes protecting them against American
flags by the way in the street Pride
Parade one of the main photos of it was
of a transgender woman which is a guy
wearing a dress but he's a trump
supporter he's a patriotic American and
he's marching along in the straight
Pride Parade because it was just people
who love their country and like their
president and support making America
great again
AOC goes on any money left over goes to
the massachusett
it's bail fund in Boston glass which is
an LGBT cue LMNOP organization bailing
domestic terrorists out of jail build
the wall keep us safe
between that debate who do you thinks
gonna win in 2020 and still the left
insists that they are against violence
very hard to make that argument when
you're bailing violent people out of
jail so how do you make that argument
with a straight face how do you say okay
we want you to give us money to bail
domestic terrorists out of jail but
we're against violence the way they do
it is they say that they're against
assault weapons which is a completely
fictitious category of weapons because
all weapons or assault weapons because
you use them to assault people even on
this the hypocrisy is totally cracking
TP USA and Charlie Kirk's organization
we talked to him a few weeks ago and you
know I give talks for TP USA a fair bit
they just put out a terrific video
exposing how hollow this argument is
this argument we're against violence we
support violent people but we're against
assault weapons TP us I approached
virtually every Democratic candidate on
the campaign trail and asked them a
simple question they asked them what is
an assault weapon you will love their
answers because it is high larious then
the hypocrisy breaks down even with our
friends over in the United Kingdom even
Prince Harry even environmentalism even
what is essentially becoming not a
political debate based in facts and
evidence and logic but a religious
debate based on a false religion we'll
see what all of that means for 2020 then
maybe if we have time we'll get a little
bit of hope from even left-wing
Hollywood but first I've got to say
goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube head on over to
the Daily wire daily wire.com ten bucks
a month $100 for an annual membership
you get me you get the Andrew Clavin
show you get the Ben Shapiro show you
get the Matt Walsh show you test
questions in the mailbag coming up on
Thursday you get to ask questions
backstage you get everything you get it
all and you get the leftist tears tumblr
this is very important
yeah this is what you're gonna need when
Biden falls apart when he says five
months out he can't even win Iowa
Democratic frontrunner you need this
vessel or you will drown go to Daley
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more so the left says sure we're bailing
domestic terrorists out of jail
sure we're intimidating conservatives
stopping them from speaking getting them
disinvited from places using the threat
of brute force against them but really
were against violence why are we against
violence because we oppose assault
weapons okay if that's your argument
fair enough just one simple question
posed by TP USA the question is for all
of the Democratic presidential
candidates what is an assault weapon I
will I will narrate because it's kind of
a little hard to see in the video who's
talking it's kind of hard to hear
exactly who it is so I'll just give you
a little pointers on which candidate is
speaking here is the Democrat candidates
answer on what is an assault weapon can
you define an assault weapon talking to
Joe
define what nasaw were talking to Joe
Sestak well the assault weapons is
reading semi-automatic and also when you
put in probably haven't even heard of
this guy he's one of the candidates
right his best answer race fast an
assault weapon is when you go over
there's an exact definition that
President Clinton had I didn't think it
before fully on Castro it gives an
example but he can't define this name it
makes an error that feeling assault
talking to marianne williamson salt
weapons are everything they're military
assault named for the job she says I
think meaning know what it
now talking to Joe Biden's wife Jill
buttons why cuz Joe Biden Erna not your
buttons wife Bernie Sanders his wife
Bernie won't even turn around to look at
the teepee USA reporter and so Bernie
Sanders his wife says there has been an
assault weapons ban since 1988 which is
not true
so not a single one of them I mean that
is a huge representative sampling of
Democratic candidates and actually if
you go over to the teepee USA video
online there are many more Democratic
candidates we don't have time to go
through all of them not one of them has
an answer they say an assault weapon is
well I don't know but the ar-15
qualifies right why does it qualify well
I know an assault weapon is anything
that is an assault weapon it's circular
logic for you they don't have an answer
it's it's not reasonable they're not
making an argument based on data now why
are they not making an argument based on
data Amy Klobuchar came the closest and
you can hear what she said she knows
it's a trap she's a smart woman and so
she says well if you want to know what
the ar-15 is look at Dayton Ohio killed
nine people there it's true the weapons
that she's talking about the ar-15 which
is the semi-automatic rifle it did kill
people there but 22 times as many people
each year are killed by handguns as any
kind of rifle including the ar-15 more
people are killed by hands feet bats and
hammers than by any rifle including the
ar-15 so if you're talking about the
actual assault weapon hands feet bats
and hammers are responsible for many
more assaults handguns are certainly
responsible for many many times more
assaults multiples orders of magnitude
more assaults so why aren't those the
assault weapon because they know they're
not going to ban handguns then you'd
have to completely abolish the Second
Amendment they don't have an answer it's
just their will it's just their virtue
signaling it is it's nearly a sort of
religious argument like on up there
there are good religious arguments and
they're bad religious arguments this is
sort of a bad religious argument to
signal an intimation that there is some
moral universe but not actually to
engage
with it in any real way it just rings so
hollow I mean when you've got major
Democrats like Maxine Waters let's not
forget actively calling his sitting
congresswoman calling for violence
against Republicans as she did just this
year it's very difficult to make that
same argument that you're the ones who
are opposed to violence here's Maxine
Waters you get out there you make a
crowd you go to their homes where their
children sleep and you threaten them but
we're the party against violence we want
to stop violence by inciting violence in
bailing filing criminals out of jail and
taking away your only way to protect
yourself against violence which is your
guns it just rings so hollow and I don't
even want to call them malicious or
frauds or deceivers I mean they're very
likely maybe all of these things but I
think it gets down to a confusion about
fact and and fantasy to a confusion even
about science and religion or at least
but between science and false religion
nowhere does this ring truer then on the
issue of climate change another top 2020
issue for Democrats everybody on the
Left virtually everyone in our culture
speaks about climate change as though
the Sun Monster is going to kill us all
and yet no one behaves as though climate
change and the Sun Monster are going to
kill us all everyone speaks about all of
these issues they say one thing but they
do another and their behavior tells you
a lot more over in the UK Prince Harry
has made environmentalism one of his
central issues and yet the same month
where he said environmentalism is gonna
be my main issue this month climate
change
Prince Harry also took a private jet
four times in 11 days but he talks about
climate change so it's ok he was called
out for it here is
Prince Harry's response rings ha lower
than ever just because it is such a
massive undertaking doesn't mean we
can't all play our part sometimes the
scale of the conservation crisis feels
overwhelming and that individual actions
can't make a difference I've certainly
felt that but I've learned that we
cannot dismiss the idea of trying to do
something just because we can't do
everything we could all do better and
while no one is perfect we all have a
responsibility for our own individual
impact the question is what we do to
balance it out so today after two years
of behind-the-scenes conversations and
planning we're going to start with the
tourism industry
so let's first define the problem at
hand the negative impacts of mass
tourism and unsustainable tourism are
increasingly in the news thanks to the
reporting of many of you in this room
you've seen it I've seen it and here we
are in the city of Amsterdam which joins
a growing list of places like Venice and
Barcelona that have become overwhelmed
by crowds oh this is so pathetic this is
so pathetic it rings so hollow and why
does it ring hollow
first and foremost his hypocrisy right
he says it's so important we need to do
something we need action Britain's we
can't keep this up
climate change is gonna kill us all and
also I'm gonna take my private jet four
times in 11 days okay so you don't
really believe what you're saying
and it's not even just the hypocrisy
Rocha Foucault said that hypocrisy is
the tribute vais pays to virtue meaning
I can acknowledge a moral standard and
yet fail to live up to that I do that
all the time so do we all so it's not
even just that it's there's the
hypocrisy aspect but then there is the
blatant disregard for the facts for the
reality for the logic here are the
scientific facts about the climate
crisis climate change all of these terms
China pollutes so much more than the
United States in the United Kingdom poor
countries especially in East Asia
pollutes so much more than we do that
there is nothing that the developed
countries at the
which countries could do to fix it it
rings so hollow because even forgetting
the hypocrisy the with the left is
addressing is not a scientific problem
it's not a factual problem it's not a
problem in reality they're addressing
their own religious longings but they're
denying the reality of true religion and
so they're trying to fix it with
politics here's what I mean because
that's a sort of complex idea that that
Prince Harry is trying to figure out the
whole left is trying to figure out and
they're not doing it very well this is
not a scientific question the pollution
and climate change the way that Harry is
talking about it is not a scientific way
if this were a scientific question we
would invade China and take over their
government slaughter the political party
that runs the country and stop them from
polluting if this really were we have 10
months left or the world's going to end
if we don't stop polluting we would have
to invade China tomorrow
China releases twenty seven point two
percent of all the carbon emissions in
the world that is double what the United
States releases and the u.s. is the
number two largest emitter of carbon it
that number that China releases is 25
times with the United Kingdom releases
it does not matter if Prince Harry takes
private jets he should take private jets
he's a prince
that's what princes do that's what the
royal family does they live a luxurious
lifestyle because they are the dignified
symbol of the country and if you don't
want your Royals to do that then you
shouldn't have Royals in the first place
it doesn't forget Prince Harry it
doesn't matter if every single
Englishman in the entire island takes
private jets wouldn't matter at all
China releases 25 times more carbon
emissions and actually forget about the
carbon look at the plastic China dumps
8.82 metric tons of plastic into the
ocean per year and that's actually sort
of an outdated number I think the new
number is significantly higher that
number comes from 2010 the next biggest
polluter into the ocean is Indonesia at
3.2 to metric tons next is Philippines
1.88 next is Vietnam at one point
three the United States doesn't even
show up on the list much less the United
Kingdom doesn't even show up on the list
but from the language that Harry is
using you would think that Prince Harry
is saving the world by getting his
countrymen to stop going on vacation
this man's family Prince Harry they used
to run the Church of England I guess
titular Lea they still run the Church of
England but that church has collapsed in
recent years and before Henry the eighth
established the Church of England Henry
the eighth was called by the Pope a
defender of the Catholic faith these
guys used to defend the church the moral
order and that's what they're supposed
to be doing but as you've seen the
church collapse in that country
particularly the National Church that
role that religious duty has morphed
into the religion of leftism
religion of environmentalism now Prince
Harry is talking about airline carbon
that would scientifically do nothing to
help any sort of climate change global
warming whatever he's talking about it
in such a way as to alleviate his
religious anxiety it's the same thing
with Democrats and the assault weapons
we know that banning all the salt
weapons getting rid of them would not
really even make a dent into the gun
deaths per year we know that gun control
laws none of them proposed in recent
years would have done anything to
prevent the mass shooting incidents that
we've seen or any of the other more
prominent shooting incidents or more
prevalent rather shooting incidents we
know that the language they're using is
moral or quasi moral and not scientific
but the left just like all of us needs
to grapple with eternal questions ternal
problems that mankind has always dealt
with the problem of pain and suffering
the existence of evil our feeling and
longing and need for salvation our need
to do penance and to atone so the way
that we've dealt with this for most of
the history of our civilization is with
religion that makes claims that seem
quite credible if you ask me too all of
those things but now because the church
has cracked up in the West
you have Prince Harry who's saying
regardless of whether or not it helps
the earth stop going on vacation just to
punish yourself just to discipline
yourself just to teach you how bad you
are for committing the sin of pollution
won't do anything to stop climate change
but you'll feel bad Joe Biden and bado
or work say regardless of whether or not
it reduces gun deaths give up your
favorite weapons most popular gun in
America the ar-15 semiautomatic rifle
give up your most cherished rights your
second Amendment rights Joe Biden says
he wants to ban all guns that have more
than one bullet in them which is to say
virtually every gun except for silly
nineteenth-century derringers what it
won't stop gun deaths won't it won't get
our life expectancy to tick back up
again even after it's been ticking down
because of suicide and drug overdoses
but at least even if it doesn't
accomplish anything real it will make
you feel bad this is a bad pitch in 2020
you know one of trumps superpowers is
something that people criticize him for
a little bit on the right mostly on the
left is evidence of hypocrisy which is
the Trump it doesn't seem very religious
you know he's not a guy who really goes
to church a lot obviously he's been
thrice married he has a complex
relationship with a religion let's put
it that way
Trump prefers things that are more
tangible he likes to build buildings he
likes money you know that the Trump game
I have the Trump board game from the 80s
and it says Trump the game it's not
whether you win or lose but whether you
win and so because of this he talks
about building the wall cutting taxes
fixing trade deficits very tangible
things now we know you and I know there
is no conflict between faith and science
that science rests on religious premises
and principles and that the smartest
people in the history of the world have
spent very long time as exegetes of the
Bible and apologists and defending
particularly Christianity st. Thomas
Aquinas one of the smartest men that
ever lived
st. Agustin Isaac Newton spent the last
years of his life interpreting the Bible
Blaise Pascal the inventor of the
calculator one of the great geniuses of
the modern era George
a father George lament with the Catholic
priest who discovered the Big Bang the
man who discovered genetics them all of
these people there's no conflict between
true faith and science but there is a
conflict between false faith false
religion and science and what the left
is peddling this election is false faith
on guns on the environment on
immigration and on crime which puts
Trump in a good position to make a
tangible case to the American people the
economy is booming unemployment is low
we have relative peace abroad and the
wall is being built he's got to get it
done though he's got to actually take
the steps in that direction it looks
like he's doing it he's got to keep it
up through 2020 and some evidence I'll
leave you just with this I'll leave you
with Whoopi Goldberg which sounds like a
threat but it's actually a good thing to
hear some evidence that the left is
going too far
is that even for well-known liberals
well-known supporters of left-wing
policies they're saying enough is enough
stop it we talked yesterday about how
Hollywood left-wingers Eric McCormack
and Debra Messing from willing race or
calling for a blacklist in an outing of
conservatives in town Whoopi Goldberg a
left winger was asked about this on the
view a left-wing show and in no
uncertain terms she said this is
dreadful your idea of who you don't want
to work with is your personal business
do not encourage people to print out
lists because the next list that comes
out your name will be on and then people
will be coming up to you know why you
speak nobody we had something called the
blacklist and a lot of really good
people were accused of stuff nobody
cared whether it was true or not they
all they were accused and they lost the
right to work you don't have the right
in this country people can vote for who
they want to that is one of the great
rights of this country you don't have to
like it
but you we don't we don't go after
people because we don't like who they
voted for we don't go after them that
way we can talk about issues and stuff
but we don't print out lists and I'm
sure you guys misspoke when you said
that because you it sounded like a good
idea
think about it read about it remember
what the blacklist actually meant to
people and don't encourage anyone anyone
to do it the polls are showing us the
candidates are showing us the culture is
showing us that the left is moving
further left this is not a cause
necessarily for alarm
obviously in the long run that's a bad
thing when you look at the short term
when you look at the elections when you
look at how this could affect our
politics in the near future you see that
the left is even losing dyed-in-the-wool
liberals like Whoopi Goldberg all of
that is good news for us who want to
restore a little bit of sanity to our
culture into our country that's our show
we got a lot more to get to got to do it
tomorrow in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
I'll see you then
the Michael Knoll show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy bori our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer
Austin Stephens editor Danny D'Amico our
audio mixer is Mike Cora Meena hair and
makeup by Jesuit alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 on the Matt
Walsh oh we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation
you